when college students join sororities
many of them do it for The Sisterhood
for a place to belong for lifelong
friendships they don't do it in hopes
that a man will invade their personal
space staring at them silently creeping
them out but that's exactly what
happened at the Kappa Kappa Gamma house
at the University of Wyoming according
to a new lawsuit six sorority sisters
say they were forced by the national
chapter to allow a man Artemis Langford
into their women-only organization
because Langford says he's transgender
now what comes with being inducted into
this sorority is unfettered access to
the house
or about you know 40 college girls live
now a house where men even fathers and
boyfriends are banned from being on the
second or third floors because that's
where the bedrooms and the communal
bathrooms are
but Langford had access to all of it
according to the lawsuit several times
Langford had chosen to sit for hours on
the couch in the second floor common
area Langford stares at women walking
past one sorority member walked down the
hall to take a shower wearing only a
towel she felt an unsettling presence
turned and saw Langford watching her
silently
the suit also alleges that he has
watched members enter the house
and sometimes had an erection visible
through his leggings other times he had
a pillow in his lap joining me now
exclusively for an interview are three
of the sorority sisters suing Hannah and
Jalen who are both Juniors and Ali who
just graduated along with their attorney
Cassie Craven from Longhorn law Hannah
let's start with you how did
how did all of this initially hit you
when you were told that a man was to be
a member of your sorority
yeah we were all shocked I can speak for
myself saying never thought this would
happen to me especially in a sorority in
a space for women we were never told it
was a unisex space we joined under the
impression that it was a single sex
organization
well Jalen I I read the accounts of what
made the sisters of the sorority
uncomfortable about Artemis what did he
say to you or to any of you that you
know that made you uncomfortable
there were a lot of uncomfortable
moments in the sorority house and it
just goes to show the importance of
women's spaces ultimately and that's why
we're here today is we're fighting for
the importance of women's spaces and
what it truly means to be a woman we
were promised from the beginning that we
would have a Sisterhood meaning only
females and our national sorority has
failed us they have blatantly ignored us
and ignored our values and valued
someone else over us in these comfort in
this uncomfortable situation
yeah well Cassie we reach out to the kkg
National chapter
and they told us that while we cannot
comment in detail on this pending
litigation it contains numerous false
allegations kkg values diversity and
does not discriminate based on classes
protected by state local or federal law
well Cassie I I guess they're relying on
federal law here I don't think Wyoming
um has State Protections in this regard
but nevertheless it looks like they're
going to lean on the feds to win this
case for them
Laura I just don't see a way out for
them they want everyone to believe that
being a woman is nothing more than
wearing lipstick and the pronouns that
you use and we all know that it amounts
to Womanhood it amounts to a lifetime of
experiences and that's what they seek to
deprive these young women of and that's
what we intend to fight for
now Cassie I guess Artemis doesn't live
in the house and according to the
lawsuit was given a waiver
so he didn't have to live there now why
why is this
Laura we've seen extreme preferential
treatment given to the individual
involved and it's it's very
disheartening that when you're six foot
to 260 pound man you're treated as the
victim in today's society but the bylaws
are very clear this is an all-women's
organization Kappa was formed under over
a hundred years ago to be that support
system for women so that they could
compete in the classroom against men and
now we just cease to exist we're nothing
more than an idea of self-identification
well Ali here's Artemis being
interviewed by the school newspaper back
in October this was last year talking
about being admitted to your sorority
saying I feel so glad to be in a place
that I think not only shares my values
but to be in a Sisterhood of awesome
women that want to make history they
want to break the glass ceiling
trailblazing you know and I certainly
feel that that as their first trans
member
Ali did you all sign up for trailblazing
to have a man live in your sorority
no we certainly did not when I joined
back in the fall of 2019
um I was promised a Sisterhood which
obviously would you would assume would
be women and so for that to
automatically change my senior year it
caught us all off guard for sure hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else